[Musique]
salut c'est Alexandra Lamy ça y est je
débarque sur Tik Tok bah ouais bah ouais
j'ai très très envie de m'amuser avec
vous sur Tik Tok le mercredi 15 mars
sort la chambre des merveilles et j'ai
envie de partager avec vous plein de
contenu plein de surprises fin de
s'amuser quoi voilà et ben j'espère à
très vite allez des bisous
[Applaudissements]
c'est parce que je vais pouvoir en fait
elle est foutue
surtout que j'ai acheté ça
pour Billy les parents de Max et Lili
sont accro au portable et j'ai envie les
grands-mères
tu t'ennuies avec nous maman
[Musique]
voilà
je veux dormir avec toi et papa il va
dormir où
ça se fait pas c'est pas gentil
c'est son lit
tu as un lit toi
[Musique]
coucou tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien un petit message pour vous
dire que maintenant c'est sur ce profil
là que tout va se passer